well
uh thanks for coming everyone it's uh
it's great i know it's
one of the last sessions of the day so i
appreciate you being here with me
today we're going to be talking about
service principles and master identity
if you don't know what these are i'll
the whole point of this session is to
explain to you what they they do what
they are
and how you can use them and why you
should be using them right
uh so my name is uh christos i work for
microsoft
progress my next slide i'm a program
manager for the microsoft identity team
i work
in the developer advocacy i like to
join user groups conferences blogs
podcasts whatever to help inspire
developers to write better
and more secure software using our tools
i'm also a father and a husband
i love open source and i'm also the
greek kick
so if you know any greeks then i'm one
anyway why are we here we are here
because
um we want to uh explain how we should
be authenticating service today
especially
in the uh in the cloud era and how
things have changed over the last few
years
uh why is this a pain in the backside
because a lot of people
try to do it and they don't always do it
right and it is
something that i failed multiple times
as well then we're gonna
we're going to look at what our managed
identities and service principles in the
azure space
which are part of the microsoft identity
and then how can we use them ourselves
through demos and some slides and
walking out of the session today
you will know at least how and why you
should be using them in your solutions
and how they can help you write more
secure software um
so uh without further ado
if we were in the room together uh i
would be asking you to uh
to answer this question how many of you
here believe that you're identity
developer pros
i would uh raise my hand i see a um
that can there is raising like weight
waving his
head i i know that not many people
like to write identity in fact everybody
hates identity i don't know anyone who's
like hey i'm excited i'm going to write
a login
page today it's going to be awesome so
identity is hard
unfortunately not many people realize
how hard it can get especially uh
going beyond just a simple signing sign
out and what have you
and lots of people get wrong in fact uh
if you if you search for
uh password reset for in asp.net
uh one of the top uh answers that come
on
google or bing whatever you use for
searching is one of the
one blog that uh contains such
inaccurate information and so much uh
insecure code like i highlighted here
like storing passwords in clear text
and you know doing the password in such
a wrong way that
um not only like people like troy hunt
went and commented that this is not a
good advice
but you know as a new developer you do a
search you find something like oh that
looks uh easy i understand what the code
is doing
i'm going to use this one and guess what
lots of companies in fact many many
companies that
uh over the last few years have made the
news
every week we got somebody else making
the news because they're either storing
data and securely they're accessing data
insecurely or the front door
the sign-in out process is um is
insecure and i don't want you to be
there i don't want you to be one of
these people i want you to fall in the
pit of success
when it comes to working with identity
ah now you might say well what does that
have to do with uh mastering but we'll
talk about that
now uh back in 2007 i wrote the system
for a customer
and you know i hand rolled my own
artisan uh
signing identity code and guess what
this is this what happens when you write
an application and you put in the public
domain
you you upload something on azure or aws
or whatever
and then suddenly it becomes a target
you might say well i'm only writing a
forum for
my friends right who who's going to be
the street but
you'd be surprised how many bots and
tools and
malicious code is out there running and
scanning anything that has a public
endpoint in order to find
vulnerabilities and it might not
might your code or your data may not be
the target but your machine or your
resources could become the
you know the trojan horse that will
allow somebody else to use your
resources to launch attacks so
it's not always about getting access to
your data is
uh is by providing a less
secure front door it means that other
things could be compromised as well
so uh i've made the mistakes in 2007 and
in fact i spent
days if not weeks if not months trying
to work out what
is oauth how the flow works why
why it works in such a way how can i you
know
create a password he said without
compromising my users
how can protect against brute force
attacks what happens if there's a
rainbow attack how where am i storing my
data there's
so many different components that we
don't realize today
that could be used to compromise our
solutions so back then i was naive
uh now i know better not to do it myself
and hopefully
walking out of this session today you'll
know that you shouldn't be doing it
yourselves either
now i work for microsoft identity and we
do have a couple of flavors when it
comes to
authenticating or allowing users to
access a service and then
allowing that service to go and pull
information
azure active directory uh you'll
probably love my
awesome handwriting here azure active
directory is one of these services that
underpins
identity for us so with azure active
directory which is neither azure or
active directory it's it's an identity
service that allows
you to authenticate users and do a few
other things
allows you to go and register an
application you register an app that
shows the intent of
using azure identity as your identity
provider
it usually comes with a client id and a
tenant id it says
this is the azure active directory
instance i want to use
and then we sometimes provide scopes
like i want to access azure resources
once i sign in
or i want to grab scopes for my apis
or i want to go and call azure services
in some cases you may have to add the
secret the
identity secret somewhere that allows
your service to authenticate against
israeli so it's not just the user's
authenticating but it's also
the application identifying itself as
the service
the problem there is that somehow we
have to store that secret somewhere and
that becomes a target
um now let's say four years ago when i
was working with a customer
i walked in and one of the things that
we did was looking at all wasps and how
their solutions were
secure and i said how did you guys
manage your secrets
well they said we have an excel
spreadsheet that is password protected i
was like okay that's perfect i i like
the file they have a central location
but
how do your applications consume api
keys and connection strings or what have
you
i'll just put them in there in a web
config
okay and now you might think well that
doesn't
that's standard practice that's what
microsoft has been telling us to do or
you know uh
app settings location or you know
config.js or whatever file you use for
your solution whether it's dot net or
something else
the problem there is that um let's say
you know the secrets and that's
absolutely fine
they're secure like you can secure your
web config section so
you know they can be encrypted when
they're running on the server fantastic
what happens to uh those developers that
have access to production
systems think about that you as a
company trust your developers to
um to write codes and to access
resources
but uh it's not uncommon for these
developers to turn against
the the company or to you know they're
let go
somebody was let go at the san francisco
public services i think that he was
working at the public transport uh he
got pissed off
but he uh he got fired now he was
allowed to go back into his desk so he
sat there nicely
he encrypted the the production database
because he had access to that
and then um that meant that he locked
down all public services
uh systems for san francisco so for
about two weeks
everything was running for free because
there was no way for the system to
charge um people that were coming in and
going
to uh the tram and other public services
now this guy was let go uh they made the
mistake to give him access to production
systems
and then he was able to go and encrypt
data in fact he was taken to court and
he was uh he was fine and he was put in
jail but
he never disclosed the uh the actual
secret the the actual encryption
decryption key so
um they had to restore the system from
some backup and that took me two weeks
what i'm saying here is by giving
developers access to production systems
or production
code willy-nilly like that can become a
target
or imagine if as a developer i'm testing
locally on my machine
and my mission gets compromised now i
don't have any bad intentions of
breaking production code or stealing
data
but my machine gets compromised i have
the sequence in some files somewhere
maybe that never makes it into
production but me having access to those
things and these files and being
available to my local machine that also
becomes a tiger for somebody else
and many times most of the attacks are
not launched
externally i'm not gonna try to brute
force github to get access to your repo
i will go via one of your users that has
something compromising on their machine
that i can get access to and then use
their information to
go and launch an attack to your uh
or scan your code or a lot of attack to
your internal systems
so these id seekers is these are secrets
that
we want you to not have to worry about
neither as a developer or as a company
yeah that's the secret and this is bad
because
how many times do you rotate data in
fact i've been at customers that
had production systems that were
accessible by people i had left the
company
two years after they had left the
company because they never rotated their
secrets
somebody had the admin username and
password to some website
and they were able to sign in because
these uh
access to those systems were obviously
uh was managed by
an identity system that was not
centrally managed like azure ad
or some other identity provider and the
second one was like there's no
there was no good practice for actually
rotating the secrets
and that meant that you know people had
access to that in fact i i did it i
i was thinking about that last night in
my first job uh
after i graduated from university i went
as a tech support
guy and uh one of the things i thought
was like
maybe we should be rotating our domain
secrets right the main
passwords for our admins because you
know everything is running on a domain
somewhere and sometimes you need to have
elevated permissions and we had
web apps that were running on our
servers back then we still had racks
inside the office
so physical servers in the office and i
wrote a bus script that would go and uh
increment the password every month uh to
the month
of the so it was like some random word
and then zero one
zero two zero three zero four zero five
so for every month i was just rotating
that was my rotation and it was easy to
get so if you knew
monday so if you knew january you knew
february and march
it was the such such a basic pattern
always there was an exclamation mark in
the end so it was obviously more secure
but that was my rotation i mean that was
better than not rotating the keys but at
the same time it was an
awful practice so rotation is something
that
if you are managing keys today you know
how tricky it is we have to remember how
often to rotate them and when they
expire
the other thing is exposure obviously i
did mention that as a developer
i should not have access to production
systems you as a company you don't want
your developers to have access to
production systems
well i still need to write code for that
but is there a better way absolutely i
will show you how
and that minimizes the exposure to you
as a developer and responsibility and as
a company
scaling as well like what happens if you
have 10 000 users
in your app today how do you manage it
when they come and when they go
if you have 10 000 employees accessing
internal systems if they're not managed
by azure ad
and have some random authentication
attached to your solution
how do you manage those users leaving
the the company right
and as i said i've seen this happening
before and finally
it's definitely error prone code my bus
scripts did not work well the first time
so i managed to look out
everybody every admin account in the
domain for the first month while i was
trying to figure out why
uh you know i wasn't the best at writing
baskets but then i'm not better any now
but
at least i don't have to do them anymore
i'm just saying that error prone
and by error pronoun also i mean having
access to production systems can also
do major things i had people wiping out
production databases because they
thought it was they were in the
different subscription on azure
so they went into their oh let's let's
wipe out the developer database
and obviously you can recover from that
but you have to erase a support ticket
it takes a couple of days
so you know it's one of the things that
we want to avoid people from
doing and security comes in layers
what do we recommend what is the
solution for
um against this how do we protect you as
a developer how do we protect your
company
from malicious access well obviously
it's a
uh it's the minus identity solution we
have something called
the azure mass identity which is an
account that is managed by azure av
and allows you to uh you know offload
that responsibility of storing the
secrets or the keys to something else in
fact you don't even have to store
secrets
right because master identity handles
the service principles for you so
service principle is a
it's it's a cloud account i will explain
that in a bit
but it does the secret rotation for you
so it's perfect it offers simple
abstractions from uh requiring tokens so
technically your application is saying
i'm going to use
my managed identity to go and acquire
token from azure id
behind the scenes you don't have to do
that and then um it will come back and
provide me the access token to go and
speak to my database or my storage
account
it works like like every other app or
service principle on azure id so
you can actually use it in your code to
do uh things as well you can go and
acquire the document manually
there's a well-known endpoint in one
habit it allows you to assign
rights to service principles via rbac
which means that if you are using him as
identity you can say i want this master
then to only be able to go and get a key
from
key vault and nothing else so
with that you don't have to worry about
that account being compromised and then
going and
spinning up resources or deleting
resources from wherever
it is available for many other services
in fact i love the
because um azure id underpins almost
everything and because managed
identities are so important
there's a major effort driving the let's
make as many
services uh compatible with smartest
identity as possible so it started with
web apps and
storage and key vault and then it
expanded to support things like
containers
kubernetes uh data lakes sql server and
what have you so you have your front end
using a manual identity and i will show
you how it works
it gives a man's identity to go and
authenticate against azure id behind the
scenes
it acquires appropriate tokens and goes
and speaks to the services that needs to
without you having to add anything what
does that mean it means that my web app
can speak to my sql server without
having
a a connection stream right i don't have
to provide a secret to that sql server
i don't have to provide a secret to my
storage account or my keyboard
it will know how to go and do it for me
uh it is exposed as a local endpoint
which is fantastic i can call it
myself through code i can do an http
call to that end point it will give me
my talking back automatically
as long as i'm running at the context of
that service and it provides end-to-end
security
now msi or miles identity is not just
used for
uh for what the dogs are saying right
because the dogs are like oh you can
access
services on azure and that's all you
need but there are other things they can
do you can actually go and call into
graph and office 365 and other services
that are part of your
tenants as a part of your organization
so it's a fantastic way to extend
access to other resources securely and
the best one
that we don't really talk about too much
is the ability to actually go from
your service your front end into another
service that you own another api
both secure with mass identity so don't
be leaving docs as the
slide says because the the capabilities
there are um
are quite wide you can do quite a few
things if you want to
uh if you employ miles identity
how does it work right uh you have your
application that needs to speak to
another service let's say keyboard right
now i need to go and grab a secret from
keyboard
and i will show this my demo uh using
some kind of a connection now i only
know where my key
all i need to know is where my keyboard
is what miles identity will do or my app
will do
is go to azure id via msi uh
call into azure the azure id will issue
the appropriate token with the
appropriate permissions and then i can
go and speak to keyboard
as long as key vault is aware of that
identity
if i am thinking about the other
scenarios like office and graph and what
have you then i can use again
a month identity behind the scenes to go
and grab my token and then as long as my
manage identity has the right
permissions
to go and speak to graph or office or
sharepoint or whatever
then i can do that as well and finally
the exact same pattern can be used for
me to
throw my application my front end say my
single page app
uh written with typescript and
javascript can go and speak into azure
id
grab the appropriate tokens and then go
and speak to my other service my other
api which is also secured
and there they will both be aware of
that and we'll both be able to
authenticate their tokens and let each
other stick i don't have to configure
anything
uh beyond that let's jump into a demo
because i've been speaking for the last
50 minutes and my voice is multiple
right so let's see what we have here i
i'm going to be using a net core as the
example but what i'm showing you here
is not limit.net or you can use any of
the azure sdks
that we have available today whether
it's java javascript
go python ruby whatever you like to
actually
uh achieve the same things however
dotnet comes with some nice
features here so i have a standard web
application that uh
that has two things here uh obviously
i'm on my local machine right now
so uh manage identity is is a notion
that only exists on azure
technically but we are faking the mouse
and the the
libraries allow you to say well if i'm
running locally
i still don't want to have access to the
seekers what i want to do let me just
make this bigger because i see that
struggling and let me hide this one
because that's totally relevant to what
we're showing here
uh hide hide
let's go into our code in fact let's go
to program
so what i want to do is i want to pull
some secrets from kibble this is what my
code is doing here
but you'll notice that in my app
settings i have nothing with regards to
where the
the keyboard is or where uh well any
secrets or the keys to my keyboard
all i have here is just some logging
information
so how does the application know what to
do in dotnet we have uh
a couple of things let me let me show
you the libraries that we're using
we have the azure identity that is
responsible for authenticating the
service
we have uh the keyboard secrets which
allows us to go and
add runtime we can pull those stickers
live but we also have a configuration
extension that allows us to bootstrap
the solution
it allows us to butcher our solution
with um
with kibble so when my my dot net core
application is starting up
if i have something in my secrets
i have some config from some config
value from keyboard
right it's actually no secret it is a
secret but we don't want to populate
this here it could be left blank at
runtime
it was a startup a startup at bootstrap
it will replace whatever value is here
with what it finds in keyboard so if
if in my keyboard in my azure keyboard
which is a service that
allows us to store secrets and keys i
have that same value
it will actually place on the fly and do
it for us
and so i have these three libraries that
i need to use
then in my bootstrap in my program and
one of the things i'm doing is
i'm saying as i'm building my my
conflict let me try this one and let me
make the code slightly bigger
as i am bootstrapping my code right
what i want to do here is i want to add
my keyboard now i'm pointing to my
keyboard but you notice i don't have any
secrets
and what i'm doing down here is i'm
using the azure
identity library to say well first i
want to try my local credentials which
is my azure cli
and that can be anything could be your
visual studio code so right now you're
not saying my visual studio i'm signed
in as my
domain account that my that domain
account as long as it has access to key
vault it will
it would also work that's what i'm
saying i want to use my azure cli
credentials
first and if if he doesn't find anything
i want to go and
use my mouse identity as i said mass
identity does not exist on my local
but machine will i will mention that
there's a nice caveat there now i could
also be doing something like new
uh visual studio credential visual
studio code credentials
uh so i can if i'm running inside visual
studio i can also use those i don't have
to use the cli
and the caveat here is as long as i have
signed into my cli
and and i have a valid token somewhere
in my cask
then it will use that one to run the
application so that's the first feed
this one is going to bootstrap my
application and populate the key there
let me close this one i don't want this
one anymore don't save and now there's
another file
i have which is in the views and we will
see this running in a little bit
called keyboard secrets and here what
i'm doing is
not only am i pulling the config value
but i also want to
a runtime go and get something from
kibble and to achieve this the code is
very very similar
i have a secret client it's a keyboard
secret client it's part of the
the azure sd case right and in here what
i'm saying is a point to my keyboard and
then use the exact same credentials
to go and um and you know get my
credentials to authenticate the keyboard
and grab my value which in this case
is uh my kv secret
let's see this running by the way right
so let's uh
let's ping this up terminal new terminal
right it's building lots of
5001 just thinking about
it where's the chat i don't know if
there's any time where can i see myself
fat oh i found it nice no question so
far which is good
uh please let me know if you have any
questions more than i have to answer
them so right now the application is
running let's launch it
loads check checks out populated during
startup
and then if i go to my secrets hello mdc
oh you rock should be you rock but
this is the information that is coming
directly from kibo where's that key
vault let's go and find it
find the right uh we know that there you
go
so here if i go into my secrets session
expired
something about tokens authentication
right
so here i have my key vault and i have
my secrets
so you'll notice that there is the kv
secret that i mentioned before
and there's the sum config value from
keyboard
so as you can see this one is running
locally in my machine i didn't have to
have any seekers whatsoever
and then i was able to run it and
authenticate against the azure cables
now
if you were in an organization if you're
running code as a team
you'll probably have a number of
keyboards one would be a developer key
vault where you may have access to those
secrets so you can actually configure
them and run them
and then in production there will be
another keyboard where
you know in your application you replace
the hard-coded
bad practice crystals key vault with
some dynamic value that comes from your
config
and then again because that's not
sensitive information it can be
something that can be stored in
a config file somewhere and then you say
when i'm running production i want to
use a different
um keyboard instance so not always using
the same
keyboard instance and that allows you to
see when the keys are rotated
who rotated them why it happened so if
something is not working
or it's broken the keyboard auditing
capabilities allow you to go and find
what's happening with your secrets you
can also find out who's reading those
secrets and why they're not coming from
your application if you're only
expecting your application to be using
them
so a lot of tight security now what
happens when i publish this to azure
like what
how is this running on azure because we
said this is local which is
brilliant now i want to see how that
manifest
manifests itself on azure because on
azure i don't have other cli writing in
my service
well i could i could have a vm running
other cli so that's a lot
okay let's see what happens when we go
into azure
so if i come here uh
i have this this application was
deployed some time ago
it's the same exact application so if i
browse into this
god man why did my sessions expire
it's fine it's fine are you
authenticating it's good
it's about security so in my overview if
i browse to my website
it's exactly the same i could also go
here and change it in fact
we can go and change the secrets so i
can prove
that i'm online let's see new version
now because i don't want to mistype it
i'll say
change dynamically
i'm going to copy this i don't ask
myself to
type in the blinds i will create that
one so you see that the current version
now so if i go back to my application
and refresh the page
check that out settings dynamically it's
working right so
this is my web app running in production
using mouse identity to go into keyboard
no secrets whatsoever
so how does this work obviously for the
website to be able to do that we need
some kind of identity something that
identifies
this exact instance to kibble
and this is my identity right inside
certain services
and i'll say more and more services are
becoming aware of that
get the ability to uh to have an
identity that identity
uh has two flavors there's a system
assigned which is something that you can
provision as part of your resource
and it's tied to your issues as well so
if i were to wipe out this website today
it will automatically kill off my my
managed identity
it's nice right it's short-lived the
keys are managed by me i just said
on and save and when it created
everything for me so
this identity if i were to go into my
keyboard i should be able to find it in
my
permissions so if i go into the root and
i go into my access policies
this is where i define who has access to
my keyboard i should be
able to find it somewhere here
this is the same one so uh this is the
identity that we're currently running
the website under
and you know so it picked up the the
same name which is great i can easily
identify that
and it only has two permissions it has
the ability to list
and get secrets that's all it has and
create secrets can change anything else
which is brilliant slot down and that
identity which is tied to my web
app can now go and access things now in
some cases you might say well
i don't want my identity to be uh
to be assigned and only live with the
resource because that's the system
assigned identity i want it to be
something i define
because i might be setting that identity
with other services or i might want to
have
somebody else in the it team assigning
those identities to me
and then me as a developer just tying
the two together so in that instance i
could go and actually add an existing
one here
and then let the website run under that
identity
easy peasy right so manage identities
allow us to uh
to have one service calling into another
service whether it's our services or
other services
and authenticate against them grabbing a
talking and being able to pass the token
and authenticate the token and we don't
have to share any secrets anywhere which
is brilliant
now uh the other piece of my
talk it's it's focusing on service
principles and
this is usually a tiki subject
or a consensus so as i said before
i was working for a company i had to
manage the domain accounts and the local
accounts
but it was all nice and easy to work
with because i was in
my own network we had a lan with the
main service
with an active directory and i was
managing all the accounts from there
and that was brilliant but you know at
some point everybody moved the cloud so
suddenly we don't have that
mode we don't have that network uh we
don't have that kind of domain where i
manage
everything and i became tricky because
how do you create a
service accounts that need to run
services right i need i need a
function or some web job or some
the daemon service running on a vm being
able to call other services securely
in the in the cloud world this doesn't
exist so
how do we make it happen well this is
where service principles come into play
i talked about operations a little bit
and this is where it gets confusing
so an app registration always creates a
service principle behind the scene so i
go into azure id
i create an operating station that also
creates a service principle
that service principle is the account
that runs behind the scenes and you can
think of an operating system as the
base class and then the service
principles as the instances of that
class
where i can go and have copies of that
the nice thing is that
i can lock the permissions for each
service principle independently of
the of each other so i could have one
service principle that maps to
an app registration that has slightly
different permissions to another
uh no so uh service business are your
service accounts
for the cloud you know era
they allow you to create automated tasks
for powershell or cli they
even allow you to sign in as these
accounts when you need to run things
you can pass them into your daemon apps
and these demon apps can
authenticate based on the account from
azure id and then acquire the
appropriate tokens they're going to
speak to other services
you can use them for ci cd i will show
you today how to use them and then we
have machine learning
and every other service that supports
these capabilities you can write
let's say a python task
and upload into uh
into service and run under the service
principle and we'll only have certain
permissions which i i love
so uh the easiest way to create it is
through the cli you can do it through
powershell you can do it in
the portal but first you create a
service principle account
and you you give it a name and then you
go and assign it certain
permissions now the nice thing here is i
can lock it down to a very very
small subset of resources in fact it can
be at the subscription level
can be at the resource group level or it
can be at a very specific resource level
so i can have a service principle that
can only speak to a storage account
and a very specific storage account
within a service uh sorry
resource group and in that there maybe i
can only give it permissions to read
the blobs and nothing else so that's
very nice as we can lock things down
ourselves now one of the things i really
love about service
principle is that it allows me to create
uh ci cd tasks that run securely
and i have a couple of demos for you
here the first demo is in azure devops
and i don't know how many of you here
use azure devops but it is
one of the options if you want to run uh
something in uh like ci cd right i
upload my codes and my repo is here in
fact
i only have infrastructures code here so
i'm using arm
and then inside my arm i have a template
which only does a sql database
deployment
so it has my my
parameters if you haven't seen them
before and then in here it says i'm
going to go and
create as a server and add a database
and this is nice the the problem is that
for creating a database
or for creating a sql server you need an
admin login and an admin password
and it's been many times when i walked
into a company and i saw this
hey we're using arm we're doing our
deployment and i was like okay where do
you store your secrets
in the arm templates but they're inside
azure devops why would that be a problem
think about that we mentioned this
before as a developer
as an id admin as a devops person i
should not have access to production
secrets because that allows me now to go
and
manage that sql server somehow and you
might say well how do we manage these
things well
you can still have secrets obviously you
can still have the username and password
but
um we we recommend that only very few
people have access to that
you use the break class approach where
you have a vault
a physical vault in your company that
somebody has to physically go and open
with the right combination pick them out
and crack the
the keys so they can have access to them
that kind of security we're talking
about
now i don't want you to ever i don't
want to see you ever doing this
what i want you to see what i want to
see from you guys doing is this
using keyboard check this out i can
actually
say add deployment time go and grab my
secrets from key vault
populate my my parameters and then pass
these parameters into my arm template
to make it happen and that means that
i don't have to worry about that again
we're using the same kind of secrets and
then
the way that this works is if i go into
my yaml file
in here i am what this yaml file is
doing in effect is saying go and deploy
this uh
this arm template uh with the uh the
parameters well this is the insecure one
so we want the secure one
here with a keyboard parameters are
coming from this file
and for the task to authenticate i'm
using service principles that service
principle
likely devos will instantiate one for me
so if i say i want to create a
connection to
my azure then it will say well let me
create an account for you sure not the
settings it's in the
service connections and this service
connection this cm internal
also exists in my keyboard
it might have a deployment principle
here right different name but this is
what is doing
the in fico things this one this is the
one that actually
authenticates due to azure id
acquires the permissions to go and speak
to key vault and then comes back and
runs my task i'm gonna i'm not gonna run
the task because it's gonna
take five minutes but i want to show you
something else right you said azure
devops works great
thank you but you know we're writing on
github fine
github in fact you can be running on
anything you can have jenkins can have
any other tools that you want to uh
work with but i have uh my repos
if i load this before but it's fine
so here i have a very similar task
i have my github action and inside my
workflows i have
a main so my main does the exact same
thing
although it's using uh github to deploy
things so what i have here
is uh i have my branches i'm pulling
from main
the exact same code and then down here i
am authenticating with
the azure cli so i'm grabbing the
appropriate producers
but in this sense i'm not using my own
account i'm using a service principle
account which i
created and assigned to this
github repo and then from there i'm
deploying things
using that account so this one is
deploying my arm templates you'll see it
using the keyboard version
and i don't have to pass secrets
anywhere at all which is awesome
but the the other option obviously would
be to uh
you can do with terraform as well so
let's go and see how terraform works
by going to my route i have another
deployment option here
and then in my terraform i have my
variables which are not
secrets right resource group is not a
secret
or the location is not a secret i need
to protect but i also have a sql server
need deploy and i need to have some kind
of a
way to protect them so my admin username
and my admin password
are using the azure key vault
provider to go and grab the secrets so
i'm instantiating this with a terraform
then i say to my terraform go and use my
service principle account
and securely go and pull these two
secrets from my
from my keyboard and then down here i'm
passing those secrets into my deployment
so you can see azure devops github
github actions and then terraform can
all benefit from
removing all the secrets all together
and mounting them now you might say well
chris
uh it's fine i mean we can stick them
into our secrets here
right the the challenge here is that you
don't really have auditing on who's
using the secrets and when
whereas if you do it via keyboard you
know exactly how often and when and by
what uh secrets are being accessed now i
had to put azure
credentials here because it is the
lowest
denominator that could have the minimum
denominator i could have to store things
however
uh me and my partner have uh jp that
will work in the same team without
an azure cli extension that allows you
to remotely
run this github actions and not have any
secrets because they're using the
managed identity
of those of that machine so right now
here
i have uh here
here i have a linux vm that has the the
task running
and if i wanted to find my endpoint
you'll notice that
i'm saying here go and find me the mana
identity uh
that is currently assigned to this
machine and go and grab the token for me
and if i
were to look into this token then
let's grab this it's going to
jwt.net and then here
if i paste this you'll notice that it
came from my azure id
the audience's management azure so i can
go and deploy things to azure
and it has all the things i need in
order to be able to authenticate and run
that mastery so i also have a job that
is pointing to that remotely so if i go
back into my github is this the one i
came from no uh again here
so here i have back in my
code and i know we're almost out of time
so inside
my deployment
inside my oh no no sorry it's one level
up
it's my workflows i have a remote
workflow i think it's this one
and in here what i'm saying is rather
than using my local uh
the hosted one i want to use a
self-hosted service that runs on my vm
my linux vm and then i'm using a
different flavor
of that login which is going to make it
into the main repo so eventually you
won't have to
use the custom flavor of this login but
this will allow you to
use the manus identity and deploy things
so again
i should be able to grab the stickers
from there authenticate and then run any
tasks i want against azure
so miles identities and service
principles allow you to do
quite a few things in effect i call them
secretless apps
and secure devops because you don't have
to worry about storing stickers in your
application and configs you don't have
to have
stickers files somewhere in your machine
you as a developer don't have to worry
about that somebody in the iit team will
manage
everything for you and then uh you can
run
all the tasks that you need in azure
by removing all the secrets so uh
there you go you should start using
service principles naturally is it 45
minutes or an hour
remember it's an hour
okay so what did we learn today
that authentication is hard but we make
it easy for you
hopefully one hour okay good we have one
hour perfect
the uh you know the amount of dentists
are great for end-to-end security
right so that means that um again as i
showed you
you start with the uh the azure identity
library
so if you haven't used the azure
identity library we haven't used the
azure sdks at all
the easiest way to get started is by
going into
here aka.ms azsdk
and from here you can choose the
language that you want to use
uh we have dotnet java javascript python
c
so everything i showed you today is
applicable to all the other services
the the key library here obviously is
identity
this is the one that manages the
authentication component inside your
uh your library and then from there all
the other services that we have as you
can see you know um
we have cognitive services in fact i did
a demo the other day uh
i we streamed quite a bit on on twitch
so i did a demo the other day where i
showed you how you can write
a dotnet core app that speaks into code
into services
using azure id to authenticate things so
as long as you
have an azure id backed up
a cognitive service because you have to
deploy that you have to have a custom
domain there's like a limitation there
you can actually go and call most of
these services using mouse dentist which
is great
i think that doesn't cover mass identity
yet is cosmos db
and that's because there's a requirement
for
the slas we have a very very tight sla
so doing a round trip to us really to
get a token and come back
means that uh doing a call to cosmos to
authenticate the us ready
would slow things down but we are
working on towards
enabling that and lighting that up
inside cosmos db as well so if you say
well
i don't really want sub 9 millisecond
performance i'm okay with 12 or 11
then you can use azure id to back things
up so that will be an option to you in
the future
i think we are working towards that and
then um
storage and everything else can also be
backed up by
azure identity which is great
ah let's see what else so we have the
azure sdk i
talked about the uh how you enable them
i told you how to spin up one so in fact
it's going to be cli
there you go z
cls clear sorry i mean i'm in a
i'm in a linux vm so i need to remember
my commands
so here if i were to create a new
service principle a z
a d s b create
that for
power
i think it's uh
it's my name we need that
and we'll say nbc london
what what did i do wrong there
i'll go help there you go why not
okay ah it was
create for our back
i'm just talking about there you go i'm
back
and
oh i need to sign it obviously sorry
guys
first before i use that i need to sign
in
so there you go that's authenticated
you know what would be if i do it inside
the portal
so if you haven't used the cli before uh
rather than doing the
remote vm because now it will be out of
context what i'm doing here
is requesting cloud soul if you haven't
used cloudsol it's
the building uh cli or power cell that
we have for
working with azure the nice thing is
that i can authenticate it so i don't
have to
do it from scratch connecting to it
and now i can do az
crickets
foreign
so now this one is giving contributor
rights to my whole subscription which is
not good
but you can go and change the role
assignment afterwards
the nice thing here is that it created
everything i need
you notice that it actually gives me a
password that password
it will be rotated for me i can go and
change it if i want to
um in fact i should change it if i will
delete the whole thing
but it created an app id for me so now i
can take this one and start using it
everywhere i want
if you were to use it inside uh
something like uh
github also you have to also say just as
sdk
auth and that will create a different
sp type which will be
uh you'll note that the output is
slightly or somewhat different
there you go thinking about it trying to
do it all assignment again it will be
a full contributor to my whole
subscription which is not best practice
you can say you can define exactly which
scope you want to give it
eventually we'll come back any questions
with regards to mast identities or
like a lot more information here now
right so your client secret cloud id
uh in in github i would grab this whole
thing and add it as my
azure credentials
so i don't know if anyone here has used
service principles or
miles identities but i hope that it gave
you a nice insight on why you should be
using them and how you can
you know get started with them and which
libraries to use obviously you don't
have to use the libraries but libraries
make your life a lot easier so the sdks
that we have for azure
make the your life a lot easier and the
reason why i'm saying that is because
for everything to start with you need a
token credential or a credential
provider and uh
you know there are options here you can
use the default
azure credential and with that you don't
even have to say what you're going to
use we'll try
uh one at a time to find the signing
credential so we'll try to find the
mouse identity we'll try to find
the um the other ones so as soon as he
finds one that is authenticated then
you're good to go
one thing that we didn't have enough
time to cover yet was
right i have i have mastered in the
clouds i have my local identity
running on my machine we have service
principles running
tasks but what if i wanted to actually
use madas identity on a machine that is
not part of azure because we've been
talking about azure
azure arc which is a service that allows
you to add
machines into your tenant
and make them look and feel like actual
azure vms is a service that
you can run anywhere so you can have a
vm running on aws that needs to access
other services
via managed identity i could have my
local machine um
being arc joined into azure id and that
allows you actually to uh
not only be part of the azure but also
have a local managed identity instance
which means that in aws you could have a
task running like this
authenticating guest azure id and then
calling azure services
without you having to pass any secrets
so arc is the extension of all these
things that we talked about
that bring the azure identity component
into any machine so rather than using my
local cli credentials if my machine was
adjoining to us rock
i could just and it's a very simple task
you run a parcel script and we'll attach
it to
an arc allows you to manage that device
as if it was inside azure
and the whole point there is that you
get the the benefits of having
a vm mouse by azure and that identity
available to you
which i find it's a it's a great
extension to everything that we talked
about because
you can go outside the azure ecosystem
and still be part of the azure family so
there you have it
uh we covered everything that i wanted
to cover today
if you have any questions feel free to
reach out to me on twitter
feel free to reach out to me on email in
fact i can
send you my contact information if you
want to
i will add them to the chat and if you
are working with microsoft identity if
you have any questions about how to work
with
our technologies then i'll be more than
happy to
help you out we also have a stream that
we do every uh
every tuesday and friday at 8 am pacific
time where
we show you how to build things like
that if you are into tweets if you are
into stream we're on youtube
on twitch and we have everything on
youtube as well after that
we talk about how identi can help you
write more secure solutions whether it's
authentication
authorization devops security
other services we cover everything and
if you have ideas for the show or
questions
feel free to join us i appreciate
everyone for coming i know it's the end
of the day for some of you maybe quite
late in europe so
thank you very much for attending my
session i'll share the
slides the demos are actually live uh on
youtube sorry on on github so if you go
into github
uh you can find all the demos here uh we
have blog posts as well that explain how
to do things so um it was great
thank you i was nice being part of the
ndc as well and i appreciate your time
thank you very much
you